mommy
it's got to be the spiciest thing you've
ever eaten in your life right it's not
spicy that's rude
what is that
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by tracey ellis ross
she's a golden globe award-winning
actress and queen of the sitcom whose
20-year plus-long career includes
everything from hit tv shows and films
to a people's choice fashion icon award
she also stars of course in blackish
currently in its eighth and final
farewell season tuesday nights on abc
tracey ellis ross welcome to the show
thank you for having me i'm terrified
well how are you around hot sauce
because i know that you do like to mix
hot sauce and potato chips but some
people have said that frank's hot sauce
is not actually hot sauce it's like a
vinegar flavored something i'm trying to
build some confidence i understand yeah
i'm not great around hot stuff um but i
feel like
i want to be but like i was thinking
about it last night as i was having
nightmares and my brothers all used to
like have competitions like who could
eat the most wasabi like i was never
that person so this is my moment at 49
i'm turning into that kid
[Music]
start at the handle this is classic so
we're start and this is number one
number one okay
okay it tastes like a hot wing
so from girlfriends handing the baton to
blackish you've really been a dinnertime
tv mainstay for decades from your unique
perspective and maybe in this state of
farewell season reflection have you
given any thought to what you think
distinguishes a good tv sitcom from one
that's mediocre yeah
i'm giving it a lot of thought
um i think it's when you care about the
people so um
i was really drawn to this couple
because they actually loved and liked
each other
because so often sitcom couples are
based on eye rolling and like you hate
your partner but that wasn't the case
with bo and dre
and so it was really intriguing to me
and i think even uh handling marital
issues and problems in a realistic way
yeah you know i think a lot of times uh
with the heavier topics or realer things
sometimes it ends up like that saved by
the bell episode where like jesse was
addicted to like the diet pills you know
it's like hard to
did you just make us save by the bell
reference it went there you know
that's amazing please continue well you
know because i mean like i think
blackish that's just kind of
distinguishes the show is that it can
handle those sorts of issues while
maintaining its comedic touch i think
that was um
the beauty of the show um and i think we
earned those moments and it was really
built into the dna of our show that we
were able to kind of do i mean if you
list the topics the themes of our
episodes you'd be like that's not
that's not a comedy like i'm not sure
what are you talking about police
brutality like you know postpartum
depression
um and i think we did we earned that
stuff because it was anchored in reality
you know it's a segway into the wings
but it's like so much you can take in so
much more spoonful of sugar helps the
medicine go down right when you're not
being punched in the face
when you're laughing you actually can
take stuff in
oh garlic
all right i want to see which section
take a big bite here we go
oh that's
warm smoky woody
what let me tell you something the tip
of my tongue is like girl
i see you girl this is a hot number two
this is the hottest number two that
we've ever had really yeah i don't think
i should lick my finger but i want to
yeah it's it's different i'm gonna get
me right now sophie's choice here it's
coming to get me right now it's coming
right up the back of my throat
it's up the back of my rope
i'm having like the coal miner cough
we're only on number two [ __ ]
wait i need ah it's all right i'm not
licking my finger
where do you find these things we
actually spend more time than you'd ever
think curating these lineups like every
new season we're kind of out with the
old and in with the news
yeah so like noah from heatonis him and
uh the show's creator chris schoenberger
when they're figuring out the lineup
sometimes i'll like walk in there and
it'll look like i'm i walked in on
something sketchy and they'll just have
like hot sauce bottles all around like
wings open they'll be like kind of dying
because they've been eating spicy food
like i feel like i walked in on
something people that like once you
start in the spicy world like it's it's
like a world yeah it's like a it's a
world i don't i don't live in yeah but
you know what it's one that you'll get a
crash course in today i'm getting a
crash question i have to tell you i
might want to take this home because i
feel like this might be something to
cook with well you know what you can
take them all home we're gonna really
some of them maybe and by the end i
might be traumatized i might be like i
don't want any of this [ __ ] i don't want
to say it again
[Music]
this is psychological warfare that's
that's the that's the tagline on our
show okay
all right well
i now i feel really frightened
i just threw a piece of the chicken on
the floor like that's all right
that's all right the studio has seen
some things
wow okay
so you've worn many hats actor director
producer but naturally i'm very
interested in the time in your career
when you're a tv host on lifetimes the
dish when you're a tv girl living in my
tv i'm gonna sing it but i gotta get all
this
meat out my mouth hold on
i was saying the um
the song what do you call it what do you
call the
theme
theme i was saying the theme song for
that uh show cause i'm a tv girl
i live in your tv and i'm a tv girl yeah
is there a sub-genre of hosting that you
found to be the least pleasant you know
for me personally it's a red carpet
correspondent always a nightmare for me
interesting
no i really enjoyed it it was also so
early in my career that i was just like
yay this is amazing
i love talking to people so american
music awards i did twice
black girls rock i did like eight times
once by myself
my favorite part of hosting is the
outfits coming up with the outfits and i
love it it's you know i said i love
conversation like i love like being in
conversation with people so to me it's
like a giant conversation like you're in
like a giant conversation with the
audience and
i love a captive audience
i love it i'm like they're all just out
there not just me that's great
[Music]
so this is the angry goat phoenix
okay here we go
oh this is gonna sneak up i'm already
dying yeah got that i shouldn't have
talked
i should just let it go down oh my god
yeah actually
it's really coming now it's really
coming it's like a slow train
it's like
no i do too that's like a slow train
yeah i got the watery eyes and then this
is the part where i'll just say you know
how you're like with my fingers be
careful around the eyes thank you you'll
sweat or something and you'll want to
you'll want to switch don't do that but
don't swipe don't swipe don't swear okay
so
okay
okay everybody we are here
so you have many characters but in
particular i'd be remiss not to talk
about the life and times of tea murder
your rap alter ego in which you rely on
siri to decode hip-hop slang and
esoteric rap references yes to date
what's the most perplexing rap song that
you've come across like have you figured
out what the no flex zone is yet hell no
i think we might be in the flex zone
right now no i don't know what the
noflex zone is i
here's what happened with t murda yeah
because of trying to not only decode but
also rap along you realize the skill
nicki minaj talks so fast and i try over
and over again very hard really makes
you appreciate what they do well you
know what though you also have a real
history because in the early 2000s
during that mtv sketch comedy show
lyricist lounge quick shout out to
wordsworth did you are you friends with
wordsworth do you know but i love
wordsworth i love words i'm still
friends with wordsworth tell wordsworth
i said hi what up words
did you have a favorite rapper cameo in
that show because it had pretty big
stars mo stuff absolutely but we had
everyone on there mary j blige i mean we
had
q-tips they were all slick rick
they were all on there
um
that show was really great and really
fun and was also at the beginning of my
career look at you just pulling out all
my [ __ ] this is fantastic that's what
we're doing
we are going
as my mouth thaws out um yeah i
but most deaf i mean and because he like
popped my rap cherry
that didn't sound right that's wrong i'm
sorry i don't mean it i didn't have sex
with him
it was rap
i'm sorry i didn't mean that i'm sorry i
would have it's a lovely gorgeous man
but i did it
i thought i was only gonna make it to
three
oh wish me luck mommy daddy come on and
join me
good luck
oh god
there's a little lever pull in here you
know i feel like we go kind of mild you
know what it's too spicy there is
another one spicy this one is like this
nice and steady but it's like it's not
this it's like like this
and i think maybe a little bit of a
cumulative effect yeah
well that's a good thing to know
i will say that it makes my nose run
well
while you use the kleenex tracey ellis
ross we have a recurring segment on our
show called explain that grammar we do a
deep dive on our guest instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context so we'll pull up the picture
over here on the monitor you just tell
us the bigger story okay
this is a good one there's a really good
story with naomi
so for my 18th birthday so i had
supermodels plastered all over my wall
naomi cindy christie linda they were all
over my wall growing up and my mom
got um
uh a phone call to do to walk in the
terry mugler fashion show and terry
thierry mugler at the time it was just
the height of fashion paris fashion week
he would do these extravaganza shows
that were not just like fashion shows he
would have performers like delight and
lip sync and all these performers would
it was amazing my mom knew i wanted to
be a model my mom said it's my
daughter's 18th birthday i will only
come if you let her come and walk to
did the show and then i went back the
second year when i went back the second
year
they asked me to wear this
um rhinestone
top that had rhinestone dollar signs
that sort of covered my breasts
and i was 19 years old like sort of
and these like red latex pants and i was
supposed to open it up at the end of the
runway and shake my boobs and the truth
is like it wasn't covering my boobs and
i was like i can't do this my mother's
gonna kill me
there's no way and naomi said to me
darling do you want to be a model or not
and i was like i want to be a model she
said then you wear what they give you
and i was like okay i'll wear it so i
put my little boobs out and shook myself
down the right way
marshall a little butt back off and i
ended up staying friendly with naomi and
that was new year's eve but there's even
more to this story i'm gonna give it to
you right now really in a nutshell
quickly yes yeah yeah that was after
we saw sandra bernhardt in concert and
then we were on our way to madonna's
house wow and that was right when she
had the sex book out
and she opened the door to her apartment
and she was wearing a bra it's a there's
a theme going on yeah yeah yeah she was
wearing a bra that had nothing covering
her boobies and she had on a mask and a
skirt a pet leather skirt and a whip
and we walked in the door and i was just
like oh my god this is gonna be quite a
new year's eve swear to god and then uh
and also naomi dressed me so that was
her coat and her dress and i had my
shoes on but she did not like what i
wore what i had on and i think i'm 22
there
wow yeah come on lots of boobs in this
that story
[Music]
oh it comes to get you yep mm-hmm okay
wait this is weird okay yes it's coming
and it's on the right side of my mouth
where i chewed and you're doing so good
i'm i'm frightened by how good i'm doing
i feel like i'm about to get killed
no i think i think we i think you were
just you're beyond frank's i think you
limited yourself at frank's did you take
it easy on me no
we don't do that just say what you will
about me but i am a chicken wing talk
show host of the highest dignity
[Music]
so as you mentioned your intro stack and
style icon awards who's been your most
stylish character would you say like is
there a role that stands out to you from
a costume design perspective
well
from a costume design perspective i will
say that michelle cole is
the
most unbelievable costume designer she
was on blackish
she did bernie mac living single i mean
it's just unbelievable what she's done
and what a treat it was working with her
and i think beau was pretty great
however
i think joan clayton like sort of stands
the test of time
um
and first season on girlfriends was a
lot of my own clothes i still have a lot
of them
can't fit in them but that's not the
point um
the fact that we were wearing louboutins
back then
joan carol clayton in her suits
impeccable and i feel like they stand up
over time like that show was 20 years
ago now and i'm still like yeah
all right this [ __ ] is gonna be bad it
says 13 angry scorpions and i've got one
scorpion on my neck you do i'm a scorpio
my birthday's october 29th anyone out
there knows that i'm very big on
birthday so the countdown is on you guys
should get the gift shopping going um
13 angry scorpions i this is the one
i've been wanting
[Music]
okay here we go
balenciaga clothes come to my rescue and
help me through
oh my god yeah media it's immediate
it's a media
it's like a
like a barbecue sauce from hell it's a
barbecue sauce from [ __ ] hell
i feel like have you ever seen in the
delivery room they put a bar over the
bed
for you to hold on to and put your feet
on yeah we need one of those i need one
of those
it's okay
so if you ever agree to do anything with
first we feast again eventually we have
to get you on our show snacked as i
understand that you're a professional
when it comes to snacking oh i sometimes
i don't eat meals just snack have any of
the sauces that you've had so far do you
think any of them could replace franks
as a go-to hell no
frank's is like a tasty seasoning these
are like a slap you in the face or as
this next one that's coming oh no one it
says it says pucker butt yeah and then
you got beyond insanity in front of that
the thing that's weird right now is
up in my gums
in the gum area above my front teeth
it's really sassy yeah it's like a warm
up
oh boy i spit on myself i'm okay do you
still snack hack with lenders mini
bagels no but god i really love those as
a child what i would do why am i like an
old man i'm like god i really love those
as a child listen what i'm
no it's the best idea it's working out
so i would almost open the whole pack of
lender's mini bagels i would do four
butter four cream cheese and i would do
tempty
and then you could do two with temp tea
and jam and then the rest were butter
with cinnamon and sugar that sounds
delicious
and i don't think any of these would
work on those
i want you to know that i can feel a
layer of fire on the inside of my
intestines that is just like it's like
i'm gonna fire you up it's like all in
there and it's it's gonna be serious
later okay so what is this
[Music]
this is so rude
i'm going into a deep meditative state
okay me too
[Music]
oh it's so hot right away it's so it's
so hot
oh my
god mommy
it's got to be the spiciest thing you've
ever eaten in your life right it's not
spicy that's rude
what is that
why would you do that who eats that what
is that for
what is that for i think specifically
for this show in this moment who's
thought of that oh you're a bad person
what do i i don't even know what i want
no no
i made a saltine yeah go for the saltine
oh
[Music]
oh my god
so those who follow you know that you're
in rarefied air when it comes to being a
globetrotter in fact the recent covetour
profile described you as the queen of
solo travel what's your name
sean who are you who why are we here
is there an audiobook that you can
recommend on a particularly long plane
ride to pass the time i have so many
audiobooks i can recommend i love an
audiobook it doesn't stop okay
i'm going to tell you about it right now
their eyes are watching god and it's
almost like a play
there's a guy by the name of casey casey
leymond who wrote a book called heavy
that will not take you for a long plane
ride it's a short it's a fast listen
um
can't think of anything else right now
because
everything's on my tongue you are
failure sorry
you're a bad wing
let the wing know let the wing know
you're a bad wing and you're a bad wing
and don't talk to the other ones because
the other ones are good wings
my butt is gonna bucker
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] right there
it's like your body's trying to like
fight it so it's like so much saliva
it's in my mouth
it's like insane
like i'm like okay because like i got
this here we go okay
so i've heard you say that you credit
being a theater major at brown for
helping you to discover your craft was
there an acting class or a student
production early on that you would
describe as a watershed moment your
acting journey absolutely
i will tell you about it right now
i was in an acting class with lowry
marshall we had an exercise
there is a phrase there's a man on a
roof and he's going to jump
and we had to stand in front of the
class one at a time
and i think i touched my nose because i
know him
is that weird
no nothing nothing is weird okay nothing
is weird so um
i
said there was a man that was on a roof
and he was going to jump off
three different ways and i won and i was
like if this is what acting is where i
get to use
my imagination
everything about myself i get to act
from my full body
i'm in i'm sold
so i don't want to eat that last wing
i don't blame you one bit i'm scared
oh my god but i made it this far
i've used this entire box to choose
we're down to the color but you know
what are you doing
oh yeah sorry so uh it's tradition
around here on the last one to put a
little extra on the last wing but you
don't have to no no no i'm not yeah yeah
don't worry don't worry
i've gone this far don't worry i need to
wipe my no my eye i mean just like
this
you're a crazy person that right you
know what you're literally like a
glutton for death
we made it
did we though almost
no tomorrow is going to be the telltale
sign there yeah let me know
i'm so
scared all i got was skin
whoa
oh this is awful
but the good news tracy ellis ross is
we've run the hot ones gauntlet and just
a little more light lifting before we
call it a day and you're a performer of
many gifts but as we've learned today
one of the strongest ones your ability
to make audiences laugh i've heard you
say that you don't even think of
yourself as a funny person but rather
someone comfortable being silly so that
in mind i want to play a quick accent
association game i'll just point to a
bottle you channel the first alter ego
that comes to mind when you think about
what it was like to eat that sauce uh uh
13 angry scorpions they're very angry
scorpions
make my my even more directions
they will come at you from above below
my heart and they will definitely get
you in the halls
to bomb beyond insanity oh my god are
you ready
they are the mom
those people are like [ __ ] here okay i'm
like
and then your favorite name the pucker
butt
every time
i go to the theater
and i see a person
a person who doesn't understand how to
enjoy the theater i think to myself you
little pokebot
you're a little
[ __ ] going out with fireworks tracy
ellis ross taking on the hot ones
gauntlet and living to tell the tale
she'd only had frank's red hot today a
crash course and she conquered and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you tracy ellis ross
this camera this camera this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life what do i have going on in
my life let me tell you something
right now my only focus is trying to get
the fire the fire out of my mind
my mouth my nose
my body no what do i have going on okay
blackish our farewell season please
watch it's such a gorgeous thing to see
the johnsons go away
pattern beauty patternbeauty.com hair
products for the curly coily and tight
textured masses
you guys can get yourself hydrated juicy
and joyful with pattern products
and i have hair tails coming there's so
many things but that's enough and all i
have to tell you is do not
[Music]
do not use da bomb hot sauce
that was crazy
that was really crazy and so much fun
i love the questions and the things that
you brought up
and it's so hard to think when it's hot
in your [ __ ] mouth
it's the best way to do an interview
it's like magic
hey what's going on hot ones fans sean
evans just want to say thank you so much
for watching today's episode and if
while you were watching you thought to
yourself you know what i would love to
try that at home well guess what now you
can because the season 17 hot ones hot
sauce box is now available heatness.com
heatness.com heatness.com to get your
hands on the sauces look at how it looks
on the inside so pretty
oh we got boom mic problems the box is
so big and you know what always with the
cautionary tale
be careful around the eyes hot ones
season 17 the full sauce lineup now
available
at heatness.com
[Music]
bye